,
Jean-Michel Leprince.
- L'église du Sacré-Coeur,
détruite par le séisme de 2010,
est encore en reconstruction,
la messe est dite juste à côté.
L'assassinat du président
Jovenel Moïse est dans tous
les esprits. Le prêtre offre
la consolation d'une présence
divine.
PÈRE DOMINIQUE MUSCADIN,
paroisse du Sacré Coeur
- Il est présent dans notre pays
malgré la situation difficile
que nous vivons. Il offre
toujours sa présence.
- Pas évident d'avoir
de l'espoir d'un avenir meilleur
pour une population pourtant
habituée aux plus grandes
violences, aujourd'hui indignée,
stupéfiée par cet acte barbare.
- Bouleversé qu'en Haiti,
que nous avons une situation
pareille.
- C'est un coup monté, c'est pas
possible que le président soit
mort comme ça, personne ne sait
rien? Où était la sécurité?
- Totalement absente, nous dit
cette voisine du président.
IVANKA JOLICOEUR BRUTUS,
voisine du président assassiné
- De notre salon, je vois
la toiture de la maison
du président de
la république. Tout de suite
on s'est dit ça doit être
un attentat.
- La nuit du 7 juillet elle
est réveillée par la fusillade.
On s'est dit ils sont venus
chercher le président
parce qu'on s'est dit,
prendre, tuer, non,
on est venu chercher,
le président.
- Depuis 2018, il y a deux
guérites au-dessus de
la résidence.
- Et là je dois vous dire qu'il
y a à peu près un an qu'il n'y a
personne au niveau de
ces guérites.
- Le président était mal protégé
et ça se savait.
Le commando est entré par
la grande porte.
En une heure de lourde
fusillade, seulement deux
victimes~: le président et
son épouse. Les autres victimes
sont 3 mercenaires colombiens.
L'un d'entre eux, l'ex militaire
Duberney Capador Giraldo dit
à sa soeur quelque temps avant
sa mort qu'ils étaient arrivés
trop tard à la résidence.
- "La personne qu'ils devaient
protéger, le président, était
déjà mort. Les colombiens, ils
étaient 26 ont été tués, se sont
rendus, ou ont été capturés
alors qu'ils tentaient de fuir.
Ils n'avaient aucun plan de
sortie, ils étaient simplement
retournés chez eux".
- La principale
agence qui les avait recrutés
plusieurs mois auparavant,
CTU Security de Miami,
avait-elle aussi engagé
des assassins? Cinq Colombiens
sont encore en cavale.
Le commanditaire
du meurtre en tout cas doit être
riche et puissant.
Comme beaucoup d'Haïtiens,
ce dirigeant d'ONG pense
à un coup d'état.
JAMES BELTIS, Pres. Association
Nou Pap Domi:
- Ça a l'air d'un coup d'état,
par exemple,
il est classique dans le cas
d'un coup d'état que
les dirigeants qui sont en place
disent à la population que nous
avons le contrôle
de la situation donc ce
discours-là le donne
àpenser dans le fond,
situation sous contrôle,
avec ce vide au sommet de
l'état, pour combien de te